what are the best questions a
screenwriter can ask themselves to make
the story better are the best questions
a screenwriter can ask themselves to
make the story better one thing is is
how is this my story how is whatever the
story is how does it relate to me so
that I can use my emotions to go to tell
this story better because what the
weirdest part about being a screenwriter
is that we sit in a room alone we are
isolated from society we basically are
cut off from emotional situations we
hate conflict we hate all of these
things that then we're going to use
those are the elements we need to use to
make our story passionate and and
emotional and all of those things so all
the things that we sort of fear to deal
with we now have to deal with and so
basically look at the story one of the
things with assignments that I have to
find a doorway into an assignment so if
I am offered a deal I'm offered some
thing that I read a book whatever some
assignment where they're going to hire
you to write the script I have to look
at that and go how is this story my
story so I can tell it honestly because
if it has nothing to do with me
then I'm just taking money and typing
and the bad part about that is the
script will not work the worst part
about it is then you may have to do it a
couple of rewrites after that on a
script that becomes torture it's like
I'm just typing this I'm just writing it
I have no connection to the story so
then it becomes work and you know if any
of us you know wanted to be wanted to do
work we wouldn't be writers so even if
the story is not exactly similar notably
the recipe yeah exactly that's me some
thing in there that that's that I can
relate to if I don't relate to the story
then it's like I don't get this so it's
like I can I had a meeting with the
people that did that did the Tom Clancy
Jack Ryan movies at once and I can
totally relate to Jack Ryan even though
I've never been in the Navy I mean you
know down the line but it's like I
amagai that that is the bookworm who
knows things but doesn't necessarily
know how that isn't the action guy so
that's the way that I can get into that
story and I think if you look at the you
know Harrison Ford Jack Ryan movies and
the Baldwin Jack Ryan movies those
really have the guy who's the
fish-out-of-water is the the Brainiac
who now has to do action stuff where the
problem with the reboot version was he
was the action guy who had to do action
stuff it doesn't work you know it didn't
work as a movie but that wouldn't if I
were offered that I would say I can't do
that story I'm not I can't relate to
that character I can relate to other
characters but I'm not sure I can relate
to that character so you kind of look at
things and go where's what's my doorway
into this story and it could be
something where it's symbolic it could
be something where you know if I'm
trying to think of some example now and
I can't off the top of my head but the
okay that the weirdest part about
assignments is that you end up being
offered things you go that's a movie so
somebody offers you Lego the motion
picture and you immediately go there is
no story there but if you find the story
in there and you go okay I'm going to do
a story about a rebel in a world where
everything is awesome I am a rebellious
type person so I can see that story so
you you find your story in there and
sometimes you look in the material and
your story isn't there you know there's
there's there's things you will be
offered that you go I could hack that
out and make money but it would be hack
work so I always try to turn those down
and try to wait for somebody to offer me
the job where I go I want to do this
project and whatever that is the that
I've mentioned the Finland story the
Finland story was a producer that had a
deal with Finland and came to me and
said we want to do a complete ripoff of
taken I'm like I don't see that but I
came up I said can I work with this and
pitch it back to you and they said okay
so they were open to that which was
great so I basically
we came up with a story about a novelist
who's on a book tour to Finland who
writes action books who's because he's a
famous novelist ends up going to a
getting invited to the world wilderness
Federation meeting the Vice President of
the United States is one of the keynote
speakers as are all these other
dignitaries and so he goes there with
his wife and his wife wears the exact
same color dress as the vice president
and when bad guys come to kidnap the
vice president's wife they get his wife
by mistake so now we sort of have our
taken situation so we have like the
wrong woman is kidnapped and now he's
got to go from being this guy who is a
novelist who writes action stories to
the action guy and so he knows all of
this stuff but has to put it into
practice so I could write that story
when I pitched it back to them they said
that sounds great and so I got that job
so sometimes when they give you the
parameters the the outside parameters of
the assignment you can find the story
inside that kind of fits within that so
it's this is like taken but it's got my
own sort of spin on it where I can tell
the story and of course husband and wife
get closer and closer as the you know
from this story because now that her
life is threatened you know they they
rekindle their relationship and all this
fun stuff that happens that works for me
as the writer you know so that's the
thing you find your story in whatever
they have or if you don't it's a bad
idea to take that job take taking you
know wait some other job okay so if the
character in the film is just someone
that's just distasteful to you that ends
up being the problem and I had oh this
is the one that okay I was offered I was
offered a script that to rewrite about a
an adult male who has a sexual
relationship with a nine year old girl
and it was heavily influenced by Leon
the professional except Leon the
professional hints it's a little romance
things and this like took it all away
and when I was offered this I said no
way in hell am I gonna
right this and I'm kind of afraid to
have another meeting with these people
and I completely turn that down because
there are characters there are
characters and scenarios that you will
be offered that you look at and go I
don't want to tell this story this I
don't want to have part of this story
there are I'm sure there are plenty of I
don't think we have horror films the
torture porn horror films anymore
because I think that's kind of faded
away but I don't think I could write a
straight on torture porn horror film you
know where it's it's all about killing
the people that doesn't do anything for
me you know that I had a while those
were hot I did a treatment for a story
that was about people who wake up in a
warehouse handcuffed to the person they
most want to kill to their warn enemy
and now have to make it through a maze
with their sworn enemy handcuffed to
them and I thought this is it I could
tell this story because it appears to be
the torture porn because of all that the
maze has all of these things where
people can get killed in it but what
it's really about is forgiving the
person that you most hate because now
you're trapped with them and now that
you're trapped with them you don't see
them as that person that ruined my life
you see them as another human being who
can help you out of these situations so
that was my my way to do that to pitch
something to the torture porn producers
that might get a yes it didn't you know
they're like you know we would rather
see them like cut each other's arms off
and escape I don't think I'm going to
write that story
you